[Music]
Baker Lake between of Canada's better
known Arctic communities it's famous for
both its artists and its industry but on
any given day life here looks a lot like
anywhere else in small-town Canada
community events are the main attraction
pretty much everyone is crazy about
hockey and family is everything
[Music]
but along with the good comes the
challenges the same ones that burden
communities across Canada's Arctic
everywhere there's the suicide problem
what we experienced in the past the
resident just cool
relocation the loss of culture and
language has really affected a
separation from family when I went to
residential school I was nine and from
there on I only saw my parents like two
months of the year new to boots premier
pledge this week to tackle an epidemic
of suicide
the risks are particularly high in Inuit
communities unities range from five to
25 times the national rate Romani no
nevel national level knew enough to
accept allah meaning but while we hear
about the issues we don't often hear
much about what happens after the
headlines and how people in many of
these Arctic communities are working to
make things right
good morning Nana see ya a goal Naomi
memo Elizabeth the MINIX AGID project
began in 1989 after the tsunami of
disclosures made by victims of Eric the
Jaeger a convicted pedophile who wreaked
havoc across northern Canada where he
worked as a priest in the 1970s and 80s
I got really angry actually when these
children were abused sexually abuse in
the community I decided to try and do
something about it
those therapists were brought in from
southern Canada at the time it was clear
that in the long term it wouldn't be
enough when you bring our therapist in
to a small community they don't stay so
I bring their own way of counseling or
we call it maybe a blue knob ways a lot
of programs get started up by people
that come in and then sometimes they die
out as people leave and it loses
interest the fact that we've been in
operation for so long and will continue
to be here is you know it's a staple in
the community people always know that
there's some place to go to
Nanuk sujeet gets the majority of its
funding from the federal and territorial
governments and is run by a volunteer
board
International now the project does
everything from counseling and community
education to traditional skills courses
and trips out on the land what we
honestly it has done is combined in the
traditional knowledge and southern way
of counseling together I think it's
important that the community take
ownership of their own healing they also
offer services in English and Inuktitut
when a client wants to talk one-on-one
and this is where we are
patty manic is many exegetes community
workers they open up more about
especially when they're speaking
Inuktitut they start showing their
emotions their anger a baker lake woman
who has to be called Doris so the man
exegete project health savor life drop
tonight that's impossible from any type
of menifee like you in fact how do I
describe what a prototype
[Music]
semion making walks is the Nunavut MLA
for the Baker Lake riding he says he's
heard countless stories like Doris's
since Munich the chief began managing
project I buying is very unique in
journalists I guess the model that they
have to provide counseling services was
created was in the community so it's
more reflective of the needs that are
required I live with the people and I've
seen people from being heartbroken and
whatnot and where they're living a
positive life now today
so it really does make a change
[Music]
Joan cash flow in the past or at the
glad-tidings
Church in Baker Lake she's also a
community probation officer
she says she refers 70 to 80 percent of
her clients to the MINIX AGID project
and has seen the good it's done
firsthand it's very challenging to have
permanent counselors in small
communities especially in remote
communities like Baker Lake the mental
health workers don't stay very long
clients do not wish to constantly repeat
themselves to new workers we're resting
men to youth they start from square one
when their probation expires some of
them have actually told me they're going
to keep going there even if they don't
have to go there they know that the
doors are always open cashless says she
like people outside of Baker Lake to
look at the good the project does and to
help it expand there are so many issues
so many problems not only in the
community but across Nunavut there is so
much help needed in our community why is
the journal treatment center in the
region why is there no treatment center
in Nunavut with assistance from the
federal government not just the Nunavut
government but from the federal
government as well I really believe that
Manistee could expand their services to
work towards becoming a treatment center
something that the Inuit has been crying
for for a number of years Jude Law says
the challenges are still many but that
community run program incorporating
traditional culture and values into
mental health services is the first step
to healing not only for Baker Lake
but for Inuit communities across Canada
I had a father who was lost for 28 days
on the line at age 81 and he survived so
I tell young people
when they're talking about suicide
look at my father who did everything to
survive so I think it makes something
you know it's a lot to do with your
identity that you had back then and the
self-sufficiency of surviving on the
land I always say there's hope we will
survive
[Music]